you think it's fair for women to require
a certain income for them to submit
[Laughter]
the way it is it is an exchange of
security and commodity for love and and
child
um I mean it is kind of I don't want to
make it out to be like I mean I know
Disney wants to make you believe that
you know love and all that starry-eyed
stuff can happen but in reality most
people are looking at you know what am I
giving up going into this and what am I
getting in return that's why I brought
up the Dowry earlier is because there is
some history that that does correlate a
bit with you have to have something in
order to get get a girl all right so so
what do you think I would say it's okay
for her to have that standards so long
as she understands that the man is going
to have standards for her so the more
you ask from a man the more the higher
standards he's gonna have for you so one
thing that we obviously see all the time
is
the more a woman
requires a man to make a lot of the time
the more attractive she has to be and
maintain for him
so if you think that correlation you
think okay well okay well the guy who I
would accept and submit to right has to
be making 100k
which is in the top 10 of earners you
better make sure you're on the top 10 of
most attractive women consistently
thanks
I mean sorry Oh Me Oh yeah um I would
say
I don't think it's fair that we put a
monetary amount on things in terms of
submission I think a woman should submit
to the man regardless of how much she
earned in that sense but at the same
time we have to just like come Banksy
said we have to base
it on reality and what reality your life
is you have to make money to be able to
submit if you want your misses to stay
at home and do nothing there has to be
enough money coming in for her to be
able to do that and for you to be able
to live that life of coming home when
your slippers are ready your dinner's
all warm and everything's all all nice
and cozy for you you have to make enough
money for that to happen that's just the
reality but I was gonna say I was gonna
say on that I think
um
if a woman is going to be the kind of
woman that she submits in a relationship
you submit to the man you choose so
there's no kind of okay this is who I
choose but he actually doesn't make
enough so I'm not going to submit it's
not that if he doesn't make enough for
you if that's the standard of yours then
that's not the man you choose
but if you choose him right then you are
inadvertently saying I submit myself to
you if that's the kind of woman you're
going to be it's the same way like we
don't say to guys oh well how attractive
does a girl have to be for you to
protect her
she's my girlfriend
does that like if a man chooses a woman
that's the woman he's chosen to serve in
the way that a man knows how to serve
well it's kind of funny because I always
hear girls say broke men shouldn't have
an opinion but we don't the guys don't
say fat chicks shouldn't have an opinion
I think it's your truth everyone can
have an opinion but that doesn't mean
people listen to you it's as simple as
that doesn't mean how valued your
opinion is exactly right that's it
that's it what is do you want you think
it's fair uh do I think what's fair
sorry yeah we use the camera we got you
come on come on I just say for the
audience issues where the spanking you
pair of trainers right now
what are you what do you think ish um
what do I think about do you think it's
fair that that men have to have a
certain amount of money
I don't really think about fairness I
think the world works the way it works
if you earn enough money there are
certain things that you have access to
or or are privileged to and so
um you find that the more you earn
the better you get
the more attractive women you're able to
attain and so it's just the rules of
nature the game is the game that's how I
just learn to play it okay so a question
for the women what percent of men do you
think make seventy thousand pounds a
year or more
in the UK
20 15 maybe
what do you think
um 15 percent
okay
eighteen percent
so according this I I think I'm reading
it right it says 60 000 pounds is in the
90th percentile
no it's not I don't I don't know if I'm
reading this right but I think this is
what it said the thing is it all depends
if you're looking at London if you're
looking at you
oh that could be oh that's probably why
let me let me break it down by London
yeah because London it has a higher much
higher than than anywhere else in the
country
um so yeah
um I'm just gonna look it up real quick
London income breakdown
but even if we double it that's still
you can ask a question for the ladies
yeah you know when you said about
um you know you said about okay this is
how much
um you know a man would have to make for
you to submit to him and obviously you
don't have to share that this
information but what would were your
answers relative to how much you earn
yeah technically yeah
so if you earned less the threshold
might be lower and if you want more the
threshold will probably be higher
the trick the trick in this in this
situation what I find is that even
though you say
um you you're happy with a man who owns
fifty sixty thousand pounds and if that
is relative to what you earn what you're
not taking into account is a lot of men
can or want to say that once my you know
once I get married I don't want my woman
to work at all so actually it's not
relative to what you earn because he may
not want you to work at all so what you
earn is zero no no but I was asking the
question of for them yeah what their
preference was as to who they would
submit to was it in relationship it was
in relation to how much they earned
okay it actually it I yeah so if you uh
if you earn half a million a year you
would still say 70k oh well no no no
yeah
yeah it's in relationship it's relative
to what you were earning because if you
can make a hundred thousand pounds a
year then why would you you wouldn't you
want something for a man that makes 50.
well no I wouldn't but I thought you
meant as in was I considering the amount
that I earn comparing it to the amount
that I would submit
the amount that I earned to the amount
that I just I'd submit to but because
because I guess let's let's even if
she's gonna look up like what the actual
percentages of men that make over a
certain amount but so do you think do
you think you're in the top 20 of
females to get that
no just like in what man value which is
like femininity Beauty well it starts
with looks femininity Beauty do you
think you're in the top 20 of females no
so then if if I then you probably would
be dating a be dating a guy that makes
less do you think it'd be a problem if
you couldn't submit to a guy that dates
last do you think that would cause
issues in a relationship
it would yeah I'm just talking from
experience from what I've said from
other people's marriages yeah yeah what
do you think
um yeah I think it most likely would
yeah
it would yeah
um
sorry what's the question
so since